hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the future of liquid handling
automation has arrived aim to do our
collaborate and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's webcast
presented by lab routes comm the leading
social media sites for science
professionals and sponsored by Beckman
culture life sciences Beckman culture
Life Sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplifying
automate and innovate complex biomedical
testing more than 275 thousand Beckman
culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences
Laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery to
learn more about Beckman cultural life
sciences please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi in your comments in
question we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today on a better look you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button on the top right or use the Q&A
button we'll make sure we try to resolve
any issues now let's get right to
today's presenters we are proud to
welcome Rajesh Kapadia Bob lund and Tim
Sherrill
Rajesh Kapadia leads the Beckman culture
life sciences automation team with
responsibilities for both product
management and market development
functions
he joined Beckman culture from Illumina
where as head of the clinical core
products group he drove efforts to move
next-generation sequencing into the
clinic prior to lumina Rajesh was the
director of the oncology and genetics
franchises at Abbott Laboratories which
held a number1 share
molecular diagnostics earlier in his
career Raj held a number of roles of
increasing responsibilities in research
and development at Ford Motor Company
and was a management consultant at
PricewaterhouseCoopers Bob lund is a
senior product manager for automation at
ethylene culture Life Sciences was
associated with the life science
automation and genomics business unit
bob has been involved in the development
of laboratory automation systems for
nearly 30 years including being a core
team member responsible for product
planning and management for the
development of the new biomass iSeries
automated workstations and the eventual
commercialization of the products if
scope of responsibilities also extends
to Beckman culture Life Sciences
thermoplastics operations in the
production of certified biomech pipette
tips and centrifugation tubes and
bottles
Kim Sherrill is a staff systems engineer
in the integrated solutions group of
Beckman Coulter life sciences he
received a degree in computer science
from the rose-hulman Institute of
Technology tim has spent his career with
Beckman Coulter in the areas of software
research and development custom
engineering services field project
management and life science automation
it's project focused in the areas of
automated data processing and last year
a new version of ethnic cultures data
management product Dart I will now hand
it over to Raj Kapoor yeah great thank
you let me start off by welcoming you
all to our iSeries platform launch
webinar and thanking you for taking the
time to join us
we here at veteran culture are excited
to introduce you to our new iSeries
portfolio which will allow us to deliver
new solutions for genomics drug
discovery academic and applied workflow
today we will review in detail our
iSeries platform associated consumables
and software suite before we dive in
here are some required disclaimers about
today's presentation
while we are very excited about the
iSeries these new products represent
only the first step in our recommitment
to innovation and to you our customers
and partners this refocus effecting
culture has been enabled by our parent
company Danaher and its standard
business system embedded in the Danner
of ism system is a focus on customers
and a drive for continuous improvement
these two ingredients give us the
confidence to commit to you that we will
be your partners and driving greater
efficiencies cost savings and more
robust solutions that allow used to
deliver repeatable reliable results our
customer focus approach drove up the
guide RI series development by the input
we received directly from you the input
that we got really came from a diverse
mix of customers in terms of multiple
markets geographies lab types and
stakeholders included a mix of phone
conversations learning from our years of
partnership with you and services and
surveys we digested all those inches
insights into five key bullets that
guided our IC series development efforts
the first thing that partners that
continuously deliver innovation is what
you told us you wanted aim a partner
that provides key products for your labs
intuitive systems designed with your
applications in mind technology that
drives efficiency into your workflows
flexible systems that are adaptable for
your changing priorities and of course
trusted and reliability and
knowledgeable support within the proxy
buy we are happy to say we have the new
eye series which is designed for your
evolving workflow priorities really from
that input we have gained the insights
of what really sets the foundations of
this product simplicity that enables
focus on science efficacy to deliver
productivity gains adaptability to
extend scale and reach and reliability
and support to reduce downtime we're
very excited to share with you the
details of how we will and how this
product does
servers on many of these key messages
now in addition to the violent eye
series we're really enabling a whole new
set of workflows we are proactively
developing automated methods for
applications are most relevant or to our
customers and our partners beyond
developing applications in our labs we
establish partnerships internal and
external to Danaher to provide
applications that our customers need
ensuring our systems can deliver the
expected results it really is this
solution stays focused that allows us to
really partner with you again our
customers and our partners for the years
to come with that I'll hand it over to
Bob to cover the details in UI series
automated workstation thanks Raj yeah so
I just want to go through a few of the
highlights of the the new biomech eye
series platform itself and this Raj is
just commented on the particular
attributes that we focused on in terms
of high-level goals for the platform
that being simplicity efficiency
adaptability and reliability and support
under simplicity we're going to be
looking at a little bit further detail
here multicolored status light bars
illumination on the deck and of course
our biomech software as many of you on
the line are probably used to from all
the years we've been in the business
efficiency we've been proved on the deck
capacity itself of the instruments new
gripper design that takes advantage of
that larger capacity deck and a large
volume 1mil multi-channel head with
selective tip pipetting that's native to
the software as well as integrated data
management and the adaptability side we
have a good base deck which allows you
to configure the deck in numerous ways
and framing of that deck we continue to
use what we call our automated lab where
positioners or else to provide
additional process
functionalities like heating shaking
cooling functions and then we also have
designed a platform with device
integration so peripheral device
integrations like readers washers
incubators storage devices the spec
thing much better access to this
instrument than previous versions that
we've had and then from reliability
standpoint we've actually added in debt
conservation system we'll talk about in
a bit here we included what we call Pro
Service remote service option that we so
to speak inherited or are taking
advantage of from our diagnostic company
here at Beckman Coulter and then of
course our user training and application
support so the bionic eye series is
available in two deck sizes or basic
configurations we call the smaller one
the biomech i-5 and the larger one on
the right the biomech i7 these two
versions shown here are ones with
enclosure the systems come with
enclosure or without enclosure in the
bottom of guide five these are single
arm platforms so you would either have a
span eight arm or a multi-channel arm on
the biomech I seven there's both single
and dual alarm systems so on the single
again we've got a single arm span eight
we have a multi-channel arm and then we
also go to the two arm systems which is
either a dual multi channel or a hybrid
version which is a multi channel and a
span II looking again at the simplicity
so you can focus more on science the
instrument status light bars show the
system status as you can see in the
pictures there on the left the top one
there with the green light bar is one
that actually with the enclosure
actually goes all the way around the
instrument so three
sixty degree in viewing some of that
input from our voice of customer that
Rajan referred to said that the our
customers wanted to be able to see from
across the lab at any angle how the
instrument was actually running or if
it's needed the tension so this the
status lady actually goes 360 degrees
around the instrument in the enclosed
version in the unenclosed version or
without the the door in the top we still
have a large link bar on the front of
the instrument which can be seen from
multiple angles
from the front societies of that of the
instrument we've also included a
illumination an LED strip along the
x-axis of the instrument it's actually
rate it contains the x-axis motion
control and underneath that that i-beam
there that you might see there in the
top left picture it's a little bit
brighter band that's where the LED strip
is and it allows you to view the deck
better and easier you want to look to
see what's happening you there's also
switch on the right hand power or side
of the instrument that you can turn the
light off if you have light-sensitive
assays for example and then we continue
to use our Bionic software we debated
about this for for a while in terms of
totally revamping our software but the
feedback from again our customers was
that they really enjoyed the Bionic
software founded easy to use and very
flexible so we decided to continue on
with the base versions of Bionic
software it is when 10 compatible and
we've also added in a few other features
we've got a new user interface that
incorporates a ribbon we also included
selective tip pipetting that's actually
native to the software we've also
included volume splitting so anytime
that you're looking to transfer a sample
volume that's larger than the
tip that's being used rather than
entering two separate method steps in
terms of splitting that volume manually
you just have to enter the the larger
volume that you want transfer it and the
software calculates how many trips back
to the source and to the destination
that it needs to do we also enhanced our
lab where library search function makes
it easier it's based on well types
manufacturers and well densities and
then lastly we've incorporated
independent probe calibration for our
spanning system which significantly
improves the ability to hit better in
accuracy or better accuracy values for
your pipetting to improve on efficiency
and deliver higher productivity we've
incorporated a large step capacity and
really we're looking at over twice the
amount of multi tighter or microtiter
plate positions on the Dex versus our
current like a biomechanics or FX
version so on the i7 series we actually
have 45 microtiter plate positions on
the i-5 we have 25 so that's up from 12
on for example on an NX and up from 20
on a FX the rotating gripper actually
has some we call that high offset
gripper fingers that straddles over
higher lamp wear so you can still pick
up adjacent shorter labware on either
side and this again allows us to to make
better use of the higher capacity deck
without having to sacrifice positions to
the right or left of the target plate
that you're after we now also have a
large volume or a actually a 1200 micro
liter multi-channel head that's proving
out to be much faster in terms
of sample transfers so instead of making
multiple trips say with a p200 tip going
say four times or five times back to the
source and then going to destination you
can now transfer a full one milliliter
with an additional 200 microliters with
the blow-up in one trip we also are
seeing that the ability to mix wells for
example with feed mixtures in a genomic
extraction procedure is much more
efficient with the one mill tips because
you can aspirate the full one mill in
for example a 1 mil or 2 mil deep well
plate I mentioned the selective tip by
petting which now is native in the
software so it is no longer necessary to
order a selective tip software as a
custom product or as a separate plug-in
product for biomech software it is now
native to the biomech software and an
individual pro calibration we're on span
8 you can actually calibrate each of the
eight probes to improve accuracy and
precision the new platform is very
adaptable we have the grid based deck
which you can actually kind of what I
would call do islands of functionality
so you can group your let's just say
various process elements like orbital
shakers or shaking Peltier's Peltier
devices all to one side you can put all
your reservoirs for example in a
grouping or Island on the deck makes it
very flexible to kind of set it up the
way you as a user would most like and
makes most sense to the workflows that
you're automating we have 4d integration
capability so the wide open spaces on
the left right and even the rear of the
instrument are wide open for additional
integrations and also the deckplates
themselves which you can kind of see
there in the upper left picture those
are removable so we can actually put
devices down below deck
and and then puts plates up and down
between the work surface itself and the
devices that are below deck and then
again just more on the device
integrations themselves you can see on
the lower left picture there we have a
number of devices there's a technical
tour saito flex flow cytometry that's
directly integrated to the to the I
series instrument there we in many cases
can do direct integrations which gets
rid of the need to have a conveyor a
shuttle that shuttles the plates off
deck and then perhaps needing a
pick-and-place robot to to move that
plate into the device we can now do many
of them directly and to the iSeries and
use the offset grippers to access that
device saves on footprint and of course
cost as well as throughput time in terms
of not having to pick and place plates
in the back there you can also see
there's a centrifuge an automated
centrifuge in the back so again rather
than having off deck a number of devices
are there washers also can be their
readers for example so there's a reader
there's a molecular devices I 3x reader
there and the middle picture and on the
far right there's the thermal ATC
thermal cycler which sits right on the
deck of the instrument in addition we
still have room to expand the systems
depending on various application
workflows so here just shows an example
of it actually happens to be an i7
instrument that's enclosed so you see
the door on the front the halo up on top
which is the blue status Lake we had
talked about earlier we can put HEPA
filtration up on top this device itself
happens have a SATA mat incubator off to
the right it's a based on a cellular
application and then on the left you see
a kind of a site extension or module the
site integrate
closure itself is the same industrial
design of the iSeries instruments and
then within that there is actually of
molecular devices I 3x plate reader all
of that is sitting on the iSeries itself
is sitting on what we call a mobile
workstation which has wheels and the
doors in the front for storage and
routing of cabling and you can also
include trash underneath there but then
also because of the the width of the
system we also have specially designed
tables that also attach to the mobile
workstation itself to get the necessary
footprint needed for this particular
design lab where feeders are another
product that fits into the mobile
workstations and again feet plates
and/or tip boxes up from underneath the
instrument to the deck itself trusted
reliability and support to reduce
downtime was actually one of the biggest
focuses for us wanting to keep
instruments up and running as long as we
can so one of those though it just
happened to be the enclosure design that
you've seen here on a number of the
slides the enclosure of course protects
the workspace on the inside from
particularly dust but then if it's more
than dust and either HEPA filtration
being positive or negative issues can be
done or simply hooking up to a external
HVAC systems with just ducting we've
also incorporated what we call a deck
observation system which is essentially
two white angle cameras there onboard
cameras they happen to fit into the left
and the right towers as we call them
which is the right in the left front
sight there as you look at the
instrument from the front
these cameras are actually always
capturing video or taking the video so
you can actually do remote viewing you
don't have to be in front of the system
customers had made a number of comments
about that they would like to know what
again what the instrument status is
while they're running a method but not
necessarily either have to be in front
of the instrument or even within the lab
so we have even our own applications
folks who aren't necessarily in the lab
at the time they're running a method but
back at their desk working can convey
the the instrument status through the
cameras at their at their desk if an
error should occur on the the instrument
we actually capture a 30-second video
before the air and 30 seconds after the
error and this can be pulled up either
by the user or by a service person to
try to figure out why the the error
occurred and they can actually look at
the video in our own experiences here
during the development it was
interesting we were asked to evaluate a
prototype thermal cycling unit for
genomics and we were doing so and like
we came back and the instrument was
stopped and we couldn't figure out why
but yes there was a plate that was
laying on the floor in the aisle and
going back and looking at the video that
was captured we could actually view that
the plate was ejected by the thermal
cycler and it broke the light curtain
which we have on the front of the
instrument stopped the instrument and
therefore you know notified us that is
needed attention so that video was a
particular use because we were able to
share that with the thermal cycler
manufacturer and they were able to make
a slight design change to their to their
instrument and and now it works fine and
again it was based on us being able to
captured the air video along with that
we have Pro service remote management
which is a tool used by a Beckman
Coulter Diagnostics we're simply using
their architecture and structure that
they have in place this is optional it's
up to
discretion of the customer but what it
did what it does provide is remote
desktop sharing viewing and also file
sharing so in many cases and what we've
seen here already in some of our beta
testing is that it's may may not be
necessary for a service person to make a
call to a customer site they can
actually troubleshoot the problem by
looking at various log files and for
example even the video if that so
happened to apply remotely without
having to go to the customer site
themselves or it will also allow them to
take a look before going to the customer
site and determine what they may need in
terms of tools or accessories that they
need to have once they do arrive on site
and make the downtime much shorter and
we've also introduced a number of
different customer training programs
including some elearning programs online
in terms of running by all Macs and just
software and also liquid handling in
general so we've we've enhanced our
training program here at Beckman Coulter
life sciences as well as our application
support whether that's application
support internally and or out in the
field itself with that I'll turn it over
to Tim Cheryl
welcome today I would like to talk
through the software solutions on the
iSeries platform as Beckman Coulter
approaches automation in your laboratory
we want to partner with you to
understand the approach that you have
and to make sure that we've positioned
tools that are specifically suited to
the types of tasks and the workflow that
you have as a daily routine and that
begins by first understanding the
problem being able to tackle that
problem with an appropriate match of
hardware and software solutions at that
point we then need to layer some methods
and the capability on top of that
instrumentation combined with any
reagents or kit chemistry which is being
brought to bear and then finally make
sure that the service and support that
should anything be needed in the future
that that's there and that everything
that is required would be done quickly a
critical component of all of this is
making sure that the software that is
positioned in the instrument is able to
accomplish all of your workflow needs
you're the different components of
software that Beckman Coulter uses that
relate together as more instrumentation
is added to a system more software
components can be brought to bear this
gives us a very flexible approach enable
to grow with you as your needs change
none of us seem to be doing the same job
we did five years ago and I don't think
any of us expect to be doing the same
job that we're doing now five years from
now and so any automation that you have
should grow with you as your needs
change as we bring software components
together we can tell that story with you
here are four different components that
go with our software tools the biomech
method launcher is targeted to an end
user or operator that will be running
methods on a daily basis it's a
point-and-click icon driven system that
guides and operator through setting up
the instrument and ensuring a successful
run the biomech software is an authoring
interface with a great degree of
flexibility that can be driven through
an icons icon driven approach for
solving workflow problems in the lab
when scheduling is needed and overnight
runs or long walk away time is desired
Sami X is a visual scheduling software
that will manage all the resources on
the system
it's an optimizing scheduler that will
find issues and resolve constraints
before you ever begin bringing things
together is the data acquisition and
reporting tool which tracks data in a
run and can manage run plate and sample
information across multiple methods and
even on multiple instruments and then
provide reports out so that you can
understand the results that have been
collected as part of your method I'll
walk through each of these in turn the
biomech method launcher is a simple
point-and-click interface for running
and monitoring methods
the goal is to easily allow you to start
a method walk through the deck set up
parameters whether that's collecting
labware such as source plates and
destination plates placing tip boxes on
deck and appropriate locations preparing
reagents that need to go on deck and the
correct concentrations in the correct
location both within a sample reagent
block or placing it on the correct deck
position within within the biomech
workspace this prevents errors from an
operator inadvertently altering a method
or by placing the library in the wrong
location this happens through an
efficient step-by-step set of
instructions that set the deck avoiding
avoiding those errors which can result
in in a missed run as the method runs
through there's remote monitoring which
can maximize your productivity and walk
away time you can be sure that your
samples are being well taken care of
both by viewing method updates through a
web browser as well as viewing the tower
cameras that Bob mentioned earlier this
also allows you to set up your your
instrument at the beginning of the day
such as homing your instrument in
preparing it for first-time use as well
as displaying data that's generated
during the run all of this works
together to give you reliable results
that in a predictable way
the biomech software is at the heart of
of our software system this controls the
instrument using a simple icon driven
method authoring interface an important
feature of the biomech software is that
it validates methods as you're writing
now it ensures that you do not take out
more liquid than is available in a while
or try to put more liquid into a well
then it can be contained it also
performs obstacle avoidance and ensures
that there no crashes on the deck any
data that's driving a method such as a
hit picking script or normalization that
needs to be done to get to a target
concentration all the information
driving that process can be viewed from
within the method or externally a 3d
simulator allows you to test methods and
to look at the precise motions that are
being done with the tip with graphical
editors that allow you to modify how the
tip behaves within the well such as a
pipetting technique editor and a
pipetting template editor method author
can also embed instructions so that the
any operator can be can follow these
instructions and set the deck properly
again ensuring reliable results simple
tasks are done in just a few clicks you
can identify the type and location of
lab where for a transfer you can simply
select the source the destination and
tips to be used configure the wealth
selection either graphically or driven
by a file instead of volume the overall
software uses a structure similar to
Microsoft Office applications for
categorizing the different operations
you can perform within the software
the add-on dart the data acquisition and
reporting tool captures data brought in
from different sources such as from a
hit picking file a biomech responding to
an integrated device such as a reader a
limb system or even manually entered
information information collected from
the system is automatically stored
whether it's from biomech or Sammy
software without any modification to the
method this happens automatically when
the biomech software transfers liquid
from a source plate to a destination
plate but any data associated with that
sample such as a sample ID or an OD
value from a reader is also transferred
to the destination and dart will follow
that data along and collected for the
destination plate as well as a source
plate data can be turned into usable
information at runtime for data-driven
applications such as hit picking or
normalization and the reporting tools
that are provided with dart include a
report that can be viewed from the web
or in Excel view where further
calculations can be performed the Excel
view has a live link back to the
original data so if any new runs are
performed using that same method or
match the filter that you've provided
that new information can be
automatically retrieved into your Excel
spreadsheet this cuts down on copying
and pasting and can avoid the use of CSV
files completely a family X workstation
solves a problem giving you long walk
away time with the higher capacity
system the power of Sam edx software
gives you a drag-and-drop interface so
there's no programming or sequel server
skills required to define a workflow on
Sammy
if step-by-step validation which ensures
that everything is connected properly
any logical mistakes are found through
review process and are highlighted in
the method off the
environment with uh with a useful
message you can address process the
details prior to running the method and
understand the setup using this the Sam
ERT function this can allow you to in
simulation watch the method run or when
running on the actual system give you
live updates as plates move through the
system you can see where they are in the
method the progress from 0 to 100
percent per plate the progress in the
overall run and the upcoming tasks that
are available access control can be used
with the 21 CFR part 11 supporting tool
that allow logins to control which
methods users have access to and whether
or not they're able to make changes to
methods or simply run method for precise
timing and to ensure that batches of
plates are processed within predefined
limits CME X includes an optimized
planning scheduler that generate
schedules prior to the run users can pre
validate these methods and be sure that
all the timings are correct for your
process if runtime data is important
that data-driven dynamic rescheduling is
supported for applications where
decisions need to be made at runtime a
good example is in cell culture
applications where based upon the cell
density the next step could be
harvesting the cells or another round of
incubation to grow more cells
this wraps up our software section and
I'll try suspect Diwali Thank You Jen so
just as we've been presenting here the
biomechanics series itself in terms of
like hardware as well as as the software
features we also view that a very
critical part of the system itself is
the biomech pipette tips and we consider
that the biomech pipette tips of course
are the most critical point of contact
because that's actually what the sample
is is touching in this case technic
Coulter manufactured file neck pipette
tips and really they're the only ones
approved for use with the Bionic
instruments because we verify and
validate them on our own instruments we
maintain a number of bio certifications
on the pipette test that being that
their DNA three RNA three DNA free both
human and mouse we take a look at PCR
inhibition assays as well on the DNA
endotoxin free and trace metal street we
have a couple special tip variations as
well that being the conductive pipette
tips that are used for liquid level
sensing using conductance and also our
whiteboard chips which from an avocation
standpoint reduce shear forces in the
tips for genomic clean ups as well as
provide better mixing in terms of bead
mixtures magnetic bead mixtures and then
also you're able to place that much more
easily and in some cases faster when
transferring very viscous samples for
example like literal stocks on the bio
makai series we actually have unified
our pipette tip design so now the tips
that are used on a multi-channel 90
six head are the same ones that can be
used with our span a platform so we
verify and validate by Beckman Coulter
or Life Sciences these tips on our
instruments we certainly know what our
design tolerances are on the hardware
itself and along with the tips they're
fully integrated with into the biomech
software including the color recognition
of the tip boxes themselves we actually
manufacture in a controlled
manufacturing environment and use
premium grade virgin polypropylene you
can see our manufacturing facility off
there on the right and a couple pictures
and if they just mentioned we we pull
samples to test for bio biological
parameters like the RNAs tienes tiene
endotoxin so with that I just kind of
want to summarize here by saying that
for those of us who have been around for
a number of years it's been an
interesting journey and quite exciting
that we now have our new Bionic ice
series product out the journey actually
started more than 30 years ago with our
Bionic 1,000 in 1986 that progressed
into the 2000 we had our first foray
into multi-channel work with the multi
MEC 96 by better and then again that
progressed to the biomech FX then
eventually NX and again into further
editions of the biomech 3000 and 4000
series but now this year we're launching
the i5 and i7 series along with that
we've also had the same journey with
various robotic arm components in terms
of external for full device integrations
many of you may still be familiar with
the former Orca arm we had from year
scale back in the mid 1990s moved into
the SI workstations even made some
industrial robotic arm 6xs arm
integrations or automated workstations
and now today we pretty much are using
scary robotic arms and or what we call
our Bert or BRT robotic pick-and-place
unit and again still allows us to do a
number of different integrations and you
know of all sizes so today just to that
point we start off with the biomech 4000
which is our low throughput instrument
platform move up into NX which is our
medium throughput and then as you can
see here in the slide move on to the i5
into the higher throughput arena in the
FX and in the i7 to the extended
workstations which we looked at earlier
in the presentation and again to full
laboratory comprehensive biomech systems
but we believe this is just the
beginning we now have a nice series
platform that's very modular and design
purposely built that way so we can
continue our innovative solutions to
meet various application workflows in
the future we are focusing of course on
our software enhancements based on user
workflows application workflows there as
well and and tie that all together with
a growing application portfolio which
can in many instances here for what we
are already offered today include
reagents but then also laboratory lab
wear accessories and and plastic wear
for example with that I'd like to turn
it over then for some questions and
answers
you
excellent presentations thanks for
bringing that information to us before
we begin the Q&A session I want to
advise that a poll question will appear
on your screen you may select your
answers then close the poll question
clicking the X in the right corner and
before we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can and our
first question is is bio mixer a
software when Windows Windows 10
compatible
okay so we will pause for a quick moment
again let me remind the audience about
the poll question that is peering on
your screen before we begin the Q&A will
we are presenting you this poll question
select your answers close the poll
question by clicking on the X in the
right corner when you are done selecting
your your choice okay so again I want to
thank our presenters for bringing that
information to us and a quick reminder
for the audience about how to reach us
today with questions questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and I see there are many will answer as
many as we can so the first one is is
biomech iSeries software Windows 10
compatible yes the software is designed
for Windows 10 and comes with an
automation controller as part of the
instrument ok am I able to transfer for
one milliliter of sample or solvent plus
you see 20% or 200 microlitre blowout
volume yeah so the 1 mil transfer volume
is certainly you can do that on a on a
span system which also can go up to 5
mils but I think the context of the
question is probably with regard to the
new 12 under microliter multi-channel
head in the answers yes so we have a tip
capacity of 1000 70 microliters so
essentially all of that volume can be
transferred but if you think of it as
simply a 1 milliliter tip the one
milliliter can be transferred but then
you have an additional 200 microliters
of potential blow out if you would like
to use that we've kind of standardized
on the 20% of blowout volume based on
manual handheld mic betters and an
audience member says I didn't hear
whether an instrument without the
enclosure has a light curtain
and it so that's actually a great
question that I don't think we did cover
so the lake curtain is available on both
the enclosed versions as well as without
enclosures what's also nice about the
the enclosed version is even if you have
the door you're able to move the door up
and down so it's a vertical door without
tripping that light curtain so the lake
curtains there and again in the case of
the open it's as if anyone has a biomech
effects or index today would be similar
so you break that lake hurt and plane
and the instrument will stop but if you
have the enclosed version as well it's
the same response but it also includes
that you can raise and lower the door
without tripping the white curtain so
again you need to trip the plane itself
and the door will not do that so you can
if you need to get into the instrument
or look closely at it or forget to put
the door down when you start the method
and want to close the door you can do so
without stopping the method or tripping
the light curtain what has been done
with error recovery in the system with
regard to having the robot continue with
a method if an error occurs sure errors
can occur from a variety of different
reasons a simple thing might be that
perhaps there was a lab where that was
placed in the wrong location reaching
into the area of the biomech to to fix
that the light curtain would break if
all the motors would have their power
cut you can then place the tip box in
the correct location even if you move
the pods out of the way you can then
click the button the first thing that
the instrument will do is to check that
the light curtain is cleared it will
move the pods back to the original
location where they were at the moment
that the light curtain was broken and
then continue on with the method now if
there's an integrated device perhaps
there's an on deck integrated thermal
cycler and and maybe it wasn't plugged
in or turned on so if there's that type
of an error
there's an opportunity to correct that
error turning turning the device on the
device can then be initialized and
either through a retry button on the
instrument and then and then the run can
continue the biomech software has a
number of different ways to recover from
those sorts of errors in an 80 or 90
micro liter pipette tip be used on the
1200 micro litre head yes it can
so an 80 micro litre in 90 micro litre
would be comparable to what some folks
may know as a p20 or a P 50 type tip so
both of those can be used on a twelve
hundred micro litre head because the the
same dimensional tolerances kind of 1070
1025 micrometer or one milliliter
pipette tip be used on the 300 micro
litre head so similar to the last
question the answer is yes so you can
put the 1 milliliter pipette tip on a
300 micro litre head as well as the ones
that were just mentioned the 80 or 90
microliter what's nice about that is is
again you can transfer all the way up to
300 micro litre volume because that's
the head volume so in the case of even
if someone wanted to do a let's say a
250 micro liter transfer with a barrier
in the tip but also have the 20%
additional blowout you would simply use
a a 1 milliliter tip and on the 300
micro litre head provide a transfer
volume of 250 and in an additional 50
microliters of the blowout volume if you
if you wanted up to 50 microliters to
get the total of 300 ok and does the
only series be placed or face out the N
X and FX or will the older models still
be available and what are the key
technology advancement differences
between older and newer models tell me
if you want me to repeat the second part
Afghan sir first yeah so the
X and FX are still within our product
portfolio I think the the one slide
there at the end showed where we started
with the four thousand went to the N X
in terms of medium throughput and then
of course the i-5 to the FX to the i7
and up into part of our extensions or
integrated systems so the full product
portfolio is still available they
provide different niches and because we
have a number of different applications
already verified or demonstrated on the
MX FX is still a reason why you know
someone might want to continue to use an
NX or FX or purchase an NX FX
though what's some of the biggest
differences in terms of why you might
want to go to the i5 i7 again the big
issue would be the deck capacity itself
which is twice that of the individual
platforms like an NX or FX those are big
that's certainly the camera feature
which we call deck observation is
something that's not available on the NX
FX on the multi-channel side we no
longer use a tip loader as the way to
load tests we actually do a force
loading so the tip loader goes away and
also because the tip loader goes away
the tip loader actually ran on
compressed air so we no longer have any
need for compressed air on the system
certainly based on the i5 and i7 itself
now there may be a need based on some
other peripheral devices that someone
might want to integrate on the deck but
certainly for the operation the i5 and
i7 there's no need any longer for
compressed air tank sterility be
maintained so on the i5 i7 in the
enclosed version we wouldn't go so far
as to say that we maintain sterility but
we would you know we do say that we can
put HEPA filters up on top so the
enclosed version is in a sense
at the basic level it's really a dust
cover if you will or protection from the
the external environment of the
laboratory or the HVAC systems within
the laboratory to add on to that if you
wanted to put sterile air onto the
surface of your work work surface that's
where we put the HEPA filters so the
HEPA filters of course would be
producing up to sterile air let's say
like an ISO five type air quality level
but then when you know what's on the
inside and how clean the system is
maintained in terms of the inside of the
instrument would be a question so that
would really be up to the individual
laboratories is how how clean make itto
the work surface itself but providing
clean air or sterile air in terms of iso
v certification the answer would be yes
can I use selective tip pipetting with
the multi-channel heads of the iSeries
you can so with the i5 i7 platforms now
we actually include selective tip
pipetting within the biomech software
today it's available but it's actually a
plugin that that we would sell as a
separate software package but on the i5
i7 it's a part of the new biomech
software where you can do columns rows
single pipette quadrants really any
configuration where you're coming in
from the external perimeter of a tip box
you can also however build up a an empty
tip box if you will into any
configuration you want for example if
you're doing a serial dilution across a
plate but you're doing it in duplicate
you would simply just grab a column or a
row depending on how what format or
positioning your plate is and just put
in two columns into an empty tip box and
then pick that up again with the
multi-channel head and do your serial
dilution and parallel across the plate
do I need to make changes to my limbs to
work with the biomass
no genuinely not the the biomech
software is able to import comma
separated values files and in a number
of different configurations in fact we
did we reached out to our users with the
independent survey and the response was
at 73% of biomech users and I never have
to consult with IT in order to pull data
reports so there's a lot of flexibility
in bringing information into your
biomech to drive something like hit
picking or like normalization and again
on the output in order to track the work
that's been done again that's something
that is can be incorporated into limbs
that the dart data manager makes this
even stronger allowing us to have direct
connections into databases Thanks ok we
have time for one last question so if we
didn't get to yours we will follow up
with you via email can I use input files
to do hit picking oh you know what sorry
let's let's skip that let's run to this
one is there a way to add a UV light
this relates to the concept of sterility
of the deck so another good question
we are always very cautious particularly
in our quality and regulatory
environment here at Beckman Coulter
we've done a number of studies on UV
light you know can it be done yes have
we done it no and the reason why is the
UV light is for any those of you who
know on sterilization wise typically UV
lights are mounted up on top and so then
you get a problem with shadowing of the
deck surface itself so you don't really
get sterilization on the deck although
you would think so because you've got a
UV light right so that's one issue also
UV light is not a very good sterilizing
technique unless it's very close to the
to the work surface itself so again
having a light three feet four feet away
from the work surface which is what
learn a Sterilite typically is not very
efficient some byproducts of putting UV
lights into systems and I've seen a
number of them out there and
laboratories whether they're on full
enclosures for example and whether
that's on bio mechs or other automated
liquid handlers platforms is the acrylic
panels on the side usually end up
crazing over time and also the UV
radiation is very harsh on anything like
tubing lines or cabling of any sort does
discolor discolor ization on you know
skins the panels for example on your
devices so it can be very destructive so
again it's just a word of caution that
keep in mind I know there's some I
believe there's some regulations
actually at various facilities I think
NIH is one of them I stand corrected on
that but where they actually do not
allow UV lights even in laminar flow
hoods because of the precautions that
they want to have from safety to the
user okay we're going to come back to
this one can I use input files to do hit
picking yes of course there's a number
of ways to bring information in that can
be done through a file again the dark
Data Manager would allow that to come in
from history even if that plate was used
on a different method where that
information was attached to the plate
okay and I do see more questions coming
in so again sorry we have to wrap up but
we the Seekers will follow up with you
after the event I would like to once
again thank Rajesh Kapadia Bob London
Jim Cheryl for their presentations
please remember this webinar is the
first of a three-part series the second
and third webinars which our application
focused are scheduled for Tuesday April
18th and Thursday April 20th
registration for both webinars is open
on the labret site what also like spank
our sponsor Beckham culture Life
Sciences for making it possible to bring
this presentation to you today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through September 22nd 2017 you will
receive an email from us learning you
when it's available on demand and
than lagoons calm welcome to forward
this announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time